au lieu de l'arrêter comme il le devrait
le policier le laisse partir le policier
est mis en examen pour complicité de
trafic de stupéfiants et complicité
d'exportation en bande organisée il
risque 30 ans de prison mais l'histoire
ne s'arrête pas là
l'affaire des 7 tonnes d'Exelmans va
connaître un rocambolesque
rebondissement
tout commence le 6 octobre 2015 au Maroc
comme chaque jour un ferry quitte le
port de Tanger pour Barcelone en Espagne
un semi-remorque en débarque et remonte
aussitôt vers la France
officiellement il transporte des plats à
tajine
mais derrière la vaisselle une énorme
quantité de drogue et dissimulée au
moins 10 tonnes de cannabis
le camion apporte destination un
entrepôt dans la banlieue de Lyon
une dizaine d'hommes est là pour
décharger la drogue
parmi eux Karim c'est la première fois
qu'un témoin raconte cette opération de
l'intérieur
[Musique]
c'est quoi il y avait des qualités
différentes et des équipes différentes
des équipes de trafiquants de toute la
France qui ont acheté ce cannabis au
moins deux d'entre elles seraient
d'ailleurs venu récupérer de la drogue
directement à l'entrepôt
res
chargés dans deux camions le reste de la
drogue reprend la route vers un nouvel
entrepôt situé à Aulnay-sous-Bois au
nord de Paris
10 jours plus tard le 17 octobre 2015
les douanes effectuent une énorme saisie
dans le 16e arrondissement de Paris
boulevard Exelmans
7 tonnes de cannabis stockées dans trois
fourgons
cette saisie assez incroyable de
cannabis hier soir en plein Paris dans
trois véhicules garés dans le 16e
arrondissement plus de 7 tonnes un
record pour les douanes depuis 10 ans la
drogue était emballée dans ses paquets
en toile
à l'intérieur des blocs de résine de
cannabis par dizaine
7 tonnes de drogues en plein Paris c'est
du jamais vu François Hollande se
déplaçant personne pour féliciter les
douaniers derrière
ces valises retrouvées pendant 7 tonnes
de marchandises ce sont des
organisations criminelles
l'affaire commence elle va prendre une
tournure inouïe
au cœur du scandale le cannabis la
drogue la plus consommée en France avec
plus d'un million de fumeurs réguliers à
17 ans un jeune sur deux il y a déjà
goûté
chaque année environ 400 tonnes de
cannabis entre Ré en France mais une
partie de cette drogue serait acheminée
sous l'égide de la police une accusation
à peine croyable qui secoue
l'institution depuis deux ans même le
scénariste le plus fou d'une série
américaine n'aurait jamais pensé à cela
un scénario insensé mais peut-être réel
mais tant en scène deux personnages hors
norme d'un côté le patron de la lutte
antidrogue en France François Thierry
un policier d'élite habitué des plateaux
télé promis au plus grand avenir la
lutte contre les stupelles se fait en
luttant à tous les niveaux de l'autre
son principal informateur Sofiane c'est
l'un des plus grands trafiquants
français
Sophiane c'est d'abord une une
intelligence
extraordinairement rapide pendant six
ans le flic et son indice aurait importé
des dizaines de tonnes de cannabis
nous avons enquêté sur cette étrange
tendaine et rencontrer des proches qui
parlent pour la première fois
[Musique]
c'était numéro 1 ça c'est sûr avec eux
nous avons pénétré au cœur de cette
affaire
déjà des cadeaux à l'intérieur avec la
marchandise on va arriver
[Musique]
imaginez que l'État puisse être
principal importateur le drogue en
France à quelque chose d'assez
surréaliste c'est pourtant bien ce que
tant à montrer l'ensemble du dossier
judiciaire
qu'en est-il vraiment en s'associant
avec l'un des plus gros trafiquants la
police française serait-elle devenue le
premier importateur de cannabis
la drogue était emballée dans ses
paquets en toile
au lendemain de la saisie des sept
tonnes de cannabis du boulevard Exelmans
en octobre 2015 l'enquête est
naturellement confiée à l'actrice
l'Office central de lutte contre le
trafic de stupéfiants dirigé par
François Thierry
c'est le numéro 1 de la lutte contre les
stups en France un commissaire
divisionnaire de 46 ans ambitieux et
charismatique
à la tête de l'actrice depuis 5 ans il
affiche de spectaculaire saisie de
drogues auprès desquels il pose
volontiers
un policier très apprécié de ses
supérieurs comme Martine Monteil
ancienne patronne de la police
judiciaire elle a connu François Thierry
quelques années avant qu'il ne dirige
l'octrice pour moi il faisait partie de
ces jeunes commissaires qui sont pleins
d'allans plein d'énergie plein
d'enthousiasmes pour leur mission quoi
donc cette volonté de faire des affaires
il était bien noté c'était un garçon
rigoureux un garçon sérieux l'homme de
la situation pour enquêter sur la saisie
des sept tonnes cela pourrait être
l'apogée de sa carrière ça en sera
probablement la fin
très vite la justice découvre la
relation contre nature qui lit le
policier un trafiquant d'envergure
international Sophia nambly
déjà condamné plusieurs fois pour trafic
de stupéfiants c'est lui qui aurait
organisé l'importation de drogue du
boulevard Exelmans
il est le principal informateur de
François Thierry
il a fait ses premières armes dans le
trafic de cannabis à Mulhouse il y a
près de 20 ans
à l'époque déjà il marque les esprits
par son culot Sofiane Ambly a été
présenté ce matin au juge d'instruction
et mis en examen pour trafic de
stupéfiant en 2002
âgé de 27 ans il est condamné à 5 ans de
prison pour trafic de cannabis
mais à peine incarcéré il poursuit son
trafic depuis sa cellule grâce à des
téléphones portables
[Musique]
le gendarmes Yves Brenner lance une
enquête sur cette nouvelle affaire
alors qu'il interroge Sofiane Hambly
celui-ci va lui faire des propositions
incroyables
il voulait monnayer sa sortie en disant
ok c'est bien vous m'avez coincé mais
j'ai des choses à vous dire et si vous
me laissez repartir je peux vous aider à
faire de plus grossier que le bien
c'était vite fait quoi
de laisser le couvercle et puis il
serait parti
non c'était pas banal
mais ça pouvait être également
monnayer avec du cash quoi
aux enquêteurs qui avaient qui avait
éventuellement sa garde avion tout était
possible pour lui tout était possible
les gendarmes refusent les offres de
Sofiane en blit qui se racontait à 18
ans de prison pour ce trafic depuis sa
cellule
mais rien n'arrête l'audacieux
trafiquant en 2003 lors d'un transfert à
l'hôpital un homme armé surgit sur une
moto en glissante dessus s'évade et
disparaît
il va tranquillement refaire sa vie au
soleil
pendant des années il vit entre le Maroc
et l'Espagne à Marbella en Andalousie
une région où sont installés de nombreux
trafiquants européens
son activité connaît alors un essor
fulgurant Sofiane embly devient une
figure incontournable du trafic
c'est ce cas accepter de nous raconter
exceptionnellement Nabil qui a travaillé
pour lui
pendant des années ce capitaine de
bateau a transporté des tonnes de
cannabis entre le Maroc et l'Espagne
qu'est-ce qu'il faut être capable de
transporter de la résine de cannabis les
petits bateaux plaisants des petits
bateaux de pêche des voiliers Nabil a
travaillé pour les plus gros trafiquants
européens parmi eux Sofiane Ambly avait
une place de choix
celui dont on parlait plus c'était
effectivement Sofiane sur la cosaures
j'étais plus connu français c'était le
numéro 1 ça c'est sûr un employeur qui
ne lui a laissé que des bons souvenirs
qui a toujours été droit j'ai jamais eu
que ça soit avec Sofiane ou son
organisation il y a déjà mis une
mensonge on n'a jamais promis quelque
chose qui n'était pas vrai
Sofiane ampli inonde la France de
cannabis jusqu'en 2009 quand il est
arrêté à Marbella par la police
espagnole
une nouvelle qui parvient jusqu'au chef
de l'octrice l'Office des stups français
comme le racontait manuel France Sten
journaliste à Libération c'est l'un des
meilleurs connaisseurs de l'affaire très
rapidement les enquêteurs comprennent
qui sont face à un individu hors norme
un très grand trafiquant avec une
connaissance extrême de tous les réseaux
de trafic entre la France l'Espagne et
le Maroc ces informations vont remonter
jusqu'à François Thierry raison pour
laquelle il va se déplacer en personne
en Espagne pour recruter retourner
Sofiane ampli qui va alors devenir son
principal informateur
est en mauvaise posture
menacée d'extradition il doit toujours
purger ses 18 ans de prison en France
collaboré avec la police peut lui
permettre de réduire sa peine
François Thierry aurait profité de cette
avantage pour lui proposer un pacte
hallucinant
en temps normal un informateur transmet
simplement des tuyaux
mais le policier va confier à ampli une
mission déconcertante acheminée du
cannabis en France
empli le trafiquant et rebaptisé d'un
terme plus présentable il devient
logisticien
c'est ce que nous confirme l'avocat de
Sofiane Hambly Joseph Cohen Sabban
le logisticien et celui qui n'investit
pas
c'est pas ça marchandise il assure le
transfert le transit depuis le Maroc ou
depuis l'Espagne jusqu'à le lieu de
destination
de la marchandise ça change beaucoup de
choses mais on regarde du code pénal on
prend un tribunal comme vous faites
passer de la drogue vous êtes un
trafiquant bien sûr la loi prévoit le
transport la détention l'acquisition la
cession tout ça c'est pareil
mais la peine c'est de zéro à 30 ans
mais la question lance qui concerne
Sofiane Ambly c'est que il le faisait
sous contrôle de la police
mais pourquoi demander à Sofiane Ambly
d'organiser l'importation de cannabis
officiellement cette stratégie
permettrait de démanteler des réseaux de
trafiquants en arrêtant les acheteurs de
la drogue acheminés par emby
elle s'appuie sur une procédure
autorisée depuis 1991 les livraisons
surveillées
l'objectif de livraison surveillée c'est
de suivre la drogue d'un point de départ
à un point d'arrivée les camions si il
s'agit de camions doivent être
surveillance constante des services
enquêteurs la finalité c'est de laisser
penser au trafiquant qu'ils peuvent
passer librement la drogue pour les
piégés et pour infiner démanteler les
réseaux de revente informé par un tuyau
d'une arrivée de cannabis les policiers
doivent se contenter de suivre la drogue
mais le duo Sofiane en oublie François
Thierry serait sorti du cadre de
livraison surveillées on serait passé à
des livraisons organisées
six années de collaboration pendant
lesquelles embly désormais emprisonnés
en France va superviser depuis sa
cellule les arrivées de cannabis
[Musique]
à l'extérieur des hommes à lui se charge
des livraisons comme Karim
faire des choses que lui c'était des
livraisons il y a des livraisons il y a
des mecs qui viennent sur Paris qui vont
récupérer
mais il y aurait plus invraisemblable
encore les complices d'Ambly aurait
bénéficié de renforts étonnants des
policiers français seraient venus leur
prêter main forte des agents des stups
de mèches avec des bandits
[Musique]
c'est l'accusation que porte cet homme
Hubert avoine qui nous a donné
rendez-vous au sud de l'Espagne
pendant des années il a travaillé comme
un filtré pour la police française sous
une fausse identité il a pénétré les
cartels de drogue mexicain
il a bien connu François Thierry qu'il
considérait même comme un ami
un jour de 2012 le chef de l'actrice la
pelle François
en Espagne est-ce que tu peux descendre
ah oui toujours
mais je l'ai appelé aussi canard Hubert
avoine raconte qu'il retrouve François
Thierry si même à Estepona près de
Marbella il m'explique effectivement ce
qui va se passer que dans le cadre d'une
procédure ouverte par le parquet de
Paris en collaboration avec les
Espagnols qui va y avoir des
déchargements de zodiaque ici et que par
la suite voilà et trafiquant on est
rechargé partir que lui arrête tout le
monde à la remonter etc il s'agirait
donc d'une livraison surveillée destinée
à arrêter en France de gros acheteurs de
cannabis marocain
la drogue va transiter par cette villa
selon Hubert avoine qui reste ici trois
semaines sa mission garder la maison et
prévenir François Thierry en cas
d'imprévu d'après lui ce sont des
policiers français dont un certain
Laurent qui réceptionne le cannabis venu
du Maroc il y avait d'autres policiers
français avec Laurent et le rôle était à
mon avis d'accompagner de gérer les
déchargements les livraisons
étaient là chargés déchargé quelquefois
ils lui ont ils l'ont aidé etc c'est
dans ce garage qui aurait été stocké le
cannabis avant d'être remis au
trafiquant directement par les policiers
au dire d'Hubert avoine dans un premier
temps Laurent venait pour soustraire une
plaquette qui était remise à priori au
trafiquant pour qu'il voit la qualité du
cannabis et ensuite quand tout le monde
s'était mis d'accord il venait avec une
voiture pour charger
depuis Sofiane ampli a confirmé à la
justice qu'il avait bien organisé
l'arrivée de ce cannabis marocain
une quantité énorme de drogue serait
passée par cette villa 19 tonnes en
trois semaines d'après Hubert avoine
qui est-elle devenue a-t-elle été saisi
en France
il soupçonne la police en avoir perdu la
plus grande part
quand je fais le bilan de ce que j'ai vu
des arrestations qui ont eu lieu on a
arrêté
trois chauffeurs avec trois petites
cargaisons vous pensez que les 19 tonnes
qui ont transité par cette villa n'ont
jamais été ces intégralement il en
manque beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
choqués par ces pratiques
uber avoine a dénoncé cette affaire à la
justice qu'il a jugé assez crédible pour
ouvrir une enquête
en tout cas à l'époque personne ne
semble s'inquiéter des méthodes de
François Thierry et de son indique une
collaboration fructueuse pour le
trafiquant
en novembre 2014 il sort de prison il
était condamné à 18 ans de détention il
n'en fera que 5
il peut remercier le policier François
Thierry s'est activé auprès des juges
pour faire réduire sa peine
emblème grand train il habite désormais
un luxueux appartement à Paris boulevard
Exelmans justement là où seront saisies
les 7 tonnes de drogues une adresse que
cette femme a pu visiter son mari était
l'un des lieutenants de Sofiane Hambly
quand il est sorti de prison il s'avère
que
c'était le jour de l'Aïd la fête du
mouton et que il avait chargé mon mari
d'aller acheter le mouton et qu'on s'est
tous réunis chez lui à eux excédent
luxueux
à Paris comme ça oui et vous traversez
un très beau jardin sur la terrasse on
s'intéressait dans un salon immense
magnifique
cet appartement le voici
un duplex de 220 mètres carrés richement
décorés
avec trois chambres spacieuses
une piscine intérieure
et une terrasse de 300 mètres carrés
Sofiane n'enblie payait chaque mois un
loyer de 9000 euros en liquide et je me
rappelle qu'il était venu avec 5 cités
téléphone iPhone dernier cri c'était
pourquoi faire ces téléphones
Sofiane Ambly est riche car il se fait
payer par les trafiquants pour
transporter leur cannabis avec la
bénédiction du chef de l'actrice
il dépense des dizaines de milliers
d'euros dans les magasins de luxe de la
capitale
comme on le voit sur ces images que nous
avons obtenu il s'offre aussi une
semaine de vacances à Dubaï avec des
amis
et c'est depuis son somptueuse
appartenant du boulevard Exelmans cambli
organise l'importation de cannabis
d'octobre 2015
il a permis la sortie du Maroc d'un
vecteur comme ils disent de leur
expression d'un vecteur qui était chargé
de plats à tajine avec la drogue
planquée derrière pour le faire monter
avec are Lyon et dispatching à partir de
Lyon vers l'Est de la France vers le
nord vers l'ouest vers le sud vers tout
ça là encore c'est censé être une
livraison surveillée pourtant l'enquête
va mettre au jour de stupéfiante
négligence dans la surveillance de la
drogue
quand le camion chargé de cannabis
arrive d'Espagne il est bien suivi par
une équipe de policiers jusqu'à Lyon
ils vont ensuite planquer devant
l'entrepôt mais on ne leur donne aucune
consigne précise de surveillance
résultat il ne se rendent même pas
compte que des équipes de trafiquants
viennent récupérer une partie de la
drogue
il ne voit pas non plus les camions
loués par ampli qui rapatrie le reste du
cannabis vers Paris
des tonnes de drogue quittent l'entrepôt
au nez et à la barbe de la police
deux policiers vont même rester une
semaine en planque devant l'entrepôt
complètement vide
la drogue désormais stockée en région
parisienne n'est plus du tout surveillée
Sofiane ampli peut en disposer à sa
guise
il en aurait alors profité pour livrer
des clients sans avertir l'Office des
stupes d'après Karim l'un des hommes
d'Ambly
à l'intérieur avec la marchandise on est
arrivé
ait des livraisons de cannabis sous le
nez des voisins en plein Paris nous
sommes allés voir le gardien de
l'immeuble
il se souvient bien de l'étrange manège
de Sofiane Ambly en octobre 2015 qui
semble confirmer les dires de Karim
[Musique]
affirme que Sofiane en blit ne l'a
prévenu d'aucune livraison c'est
pourtant son rôle en tant qu'informateur
avertir la police pour qu'elle procède
aux saisies et aux arrestations des
acheteurs
[Musique]
autre exemple une cargaison de deux
tonnes par un destination de Nantes
mais celle-ci est interceptée par les
douanes
là encore Ambly n'a pas averti François
Thierry le policier l'a reconnu devant
un juge
son informateur prend des libertés avec
la drogue mais François Thierry
n'intervient pas et ne prévient pas la
justice
quatre jours plus tard c'est la saisie
des 7 tonnes du boulevard Exelmans
là aussi le policier affirme qu'il ne
savait pas quand blice stockait la
drogue ici
nous avons joint au téléphone un ancien
policier habitué de ses opérations
pour lui laisser la drogue sans
surveillance est une incompréhensible
négligeante
sous mes fenêtres il fallait qu'il y ait
des gens pour vérifier et pour
surveiller ça des gens de l'Autriche
quoi on ne peut pas la laisser sous la
surveillance de l'informateur
de dire à tout moment à l'autorité
judiciaire bah voilà la cam elle est à
Paris elle est dans une fourgonnette il
y a tant elle s'est déplacée là et on
est derrière et on vous informe de tout
le développement quoi
la livraison n'était donc pas surveillée
quelques jours après la saisie
d’exelmans en billets François Thierry
se voit à Paris
la justice est en saisie de la faire
lundi qui est désormais recherché
mais après six années de collaboration
leur destin sont liés
au lieu de l'arrêter comme il le devrait
le policier le laisse partir
en cavale il ne sera repris que quatre
mois plus tard en Belgique
une attitude que la justice reproche
aujourd'hui au commissaire Thierry
tout comme le fait de n'avoir pas
surveillé la drogue et de l'avoir laissé
entièrement entre les mains de Sofiane
Ambly
le policier est mis en examen pour
complicité de trafic de stupéfiants et
complicité d'exportation en bande
organisée il risque 30 ans de prison
mais l'histoire ne s'arrête pas là
l'affaire des 7 tonnes d'exeels
que rebondissement
lors de la saisie les doigts n'auraient
en effet ratés plusieurs fourgons des
véhicules bourrés de cannabis garés dans
la cour de Sofiane Hambly
qu'est devenu cette drogue
une femme affirme le savoir
son mari était l'un des proches de
Sofiane Hambly
c'est la première fois qu'elle accepte
de parler
c'est qui Sofiane Hambly par rapport à
votre mari
des services d'ordre personnel moi je
pensais que c'était son ami parce que
mon mari le conseillerait comme un ami
mais c'était pas le cas de remplir
quelques jours après la saisie d'examens
Sophia n'enblie aurait demandé à son
mari Djamel d'effectuer une livraison de
cannabis en Belgique mais cette
livraison n'arrivera jamais à
destination Jamel est arrêté juste après
la frontière et incarcérée à la prison
de Mons
[Musique]
il a été attrapé
dans un camion
chargé de 6 tonnes de cannabis à la
frontière
franco-belge du côté belge
tonne de cannabis encore un record pour
les douanes belges cette fois-ci une
semaine après les 7 tonnes d'Exelmans
pour la justice française il s'agit de
la même cargaison
selon cette femme son mari ne savait pas
que Sophia nambi était en cheville avec
la police
quand il a appris il a décidé de faire
des révélations explosives
elles vont donner une nouvelle ampleur à
cette affaire déjà hors norme
au début de l'opération d'Exelmans
Sofiane ampli affirmait à François
Thierry que le camion venu du Maroc
contenait environ 10 tonnes de cannabis
mais d'après Jamel s'est en réalité une
cargaison bien plus importante qui
aurait été importée
[Musique]
à écouter son avocat il s'agirait même
d'une quantité astronomique
il ne savait pas que la police était
derrière tout cela lorsqu'il a découvert
le poteau rose il s'est senti trahi et
il a choisi de dire la vérité au juge de
dire le mode opératoire de donner les
quantités les tonnages qui sont
stupéfiants sont mauvais jeu de mots on
parle de 40 tonnes
40 tonnes 4 fois la quantité annoncée
par Sofiane
l'informateur logisticien aurait-il
transporté beaucoup plus de drogues que
prévu pour faire fructifier ses propres
affaires
vous dites c'est un justicien donc
la drogue n'est pas à lui est-ce qu'on
peut être sûr finalement que en plus de
transporter de la drogue il en transport
pas pour son propre compte puisqu'il a
été trafiquant des années il connaît les
fournisseurs rien n'empêche lui-même
aussi de faire venir la drogue à lui de
la revente
est-ce qu'on peut en être sur non bien
sûr intellectuellement je peux pas vous
dire qu'on
ne que c'est impossible
franchement
ce serait d'une bêtise consternante de
sa part
serait d'une bêtise consternante de sa
part de faire ça et le garçon est trop
calculateur pour se prendre ce genre de
risque j'y crois pas
il y a pourtant des raisons d'y croire
au-delà du témoignage de Jamel
neuf mois après la saisie d'exécellement
on découvre dans la cellule de Sofiane
Ambly un document manuscrit selon les
enquêteurs il s'agirait de toutes les
livraisons effectuées suite à l'arrivée
du camion en France
d'après leur calcul le poids total du
chargement serait de 30 tonnes c'est
environ un mois de consommation pour
toute la France
pour la police l'affaire d'Exelmans
c'est un fiasco monumental
des tonnes de cannabis seraient disparus
et le chef de l'actrice est mise en
examen
a-t-il été négligent s'est-il fait
doubler par plus brillant que lui le
trafiquant Sofiane ampli
rien n'est moins sûr
d'après notre enquête François Thierry
aurait su que des tonnes de drogues
disparaissaient dans la nature
sa stratégie serait même viciée depuis
le début
un policier français en post en Espagne
Patrick g l'avait dénoncé dès 2010 mais
personne ne l'avait écouté
[Musique]
depuis il a écrit une note à la police
des polices que nous avons pu nous
procurer
il y décrit les dysfonctionnements de
Myrmidon c'est le nom donné par le chef
de l'actrice à sa stratégie de lutte
contre les stups
[Musique]
en janvier 2010 sur cette plage de
Marbella Patrick suit une livraison
surveillée organisée par François
Thierry
à 3 heures du matin une cargaison d'une
tonne et demi de cannabis arrive du
Maroc
mais très vite plusieurs choses de choc
comme il l'écrit dans sa note
les policiers français prenaient une
part active à la réception de la
marchandise en compagnie ou grâce à des
informations
il s'agissait pour moi ni plus ni moins
que d'une importation de stupéfiant
organisée de A à Z avec l'aide
d'informateur
[Musique]
des accusations en tout point similaires
à celle du Berre avoine concernant la
livraison de 2012
autre anomalie selon Patrick que nous
avons joint par téléphone les voitures
des trafiquants n'auraient pas été
suivies par les policiers mais seulement
équipés de balises GPS
50 km sur 1000 Bornes par exemple un
petit peu garantir que il y a un
déchargement une livraison en cours de
route ou un changement de véhicule
personne peut le dire
depuis le début perdre du cannabis ne
semblait donc pas gêné François Thierry
[Musique]
c'est ce que démontre aussi un autre
événement
début 2015 lors d'une livraison
surveillée à Rouen 3 tonnes de cannabis
c'était volatilisés
le policier soupçonné d'avoir laissé
disparaître cette drogue il est aussi
mis en examen pour cette affaire
la collaboration entre le flic et son
indicateur a duré 6 ans
pourtant un grain de sable aurait pu
enrayer cette mécanique bien rodée
car les autorités espagnoles qui
accordent les livraisons surveillées
demandent des comptes à la police
française
quelle quantité de drogues ont
finalement été saisie en France
les réponses fournies par l'actrice
tenaient parfois du tour de passe-passe
un témoin de ces méthodes a accepté de
nous en parler Michel Zuera c'est un
ancien commissaire de police à
l'ambassade de France à Madrid
il était chargé de faire le lien entre
la France et l'Espagne
à la suite d'une livraison surveillée
les Espagnols demandent à l'actrice un
bilan chiffré de l'opération Michel
Zueras va se trouver très embarrassée
en la réponse a été des plus des plus
maladroites puisque
ça a été justifié par des affaires qui
étaient intérieures à la livraison
surveille
en France avant même que la livraison
surveillée n'arrive en Espagne si on
vous livre de la marchandise
le 30 mars et que vous dites que vous
l'avez saisi le 15 du mois
c'est pour le moins
curieux donc c'était manifestement pas
la même marchandise
ça n'a rien à voir
les Espagnols ne furent pas dupe de la
réponse de l'actrice selon Michel
zoueras il signale le problème à saillir
archi mais n'aura jamais de retour
des chiffres arrangés des livraisons pas
surveillés des cargaisons jamais saisies
pourquoi François Thierry aurait-il
volontairement laissé entrer en France
des quantités importantes de cannabis
[Musique]
c'est un bon connaisseur du trafic qui
va nous donner un début de réponse
Nabil celui qui transportait du cannabis
depuis le Maroc pour remplir
en s'appuyant sur un gros importateur
comme en blit le policier n'aurait pas
eu le choix pour ne pas le comprendre il
ne pouvait saisir qu'une petite partie
de la drogue
[Musique]
vous faites monter 20 tonnes c'est pas
20 tonnes pour la même personne vous
avez plusieurs équipes ces équipes
d'acheteurs
et que sur les différentes équipes vous
en saisissez 14 ou 15 vous allez faire
une phrase
parce que tout le monde va savoir qu'il
y a un problème on peut arrêter une
équipe mais vous pouvez pas arrêter huit
équipes pour une mauvaise chance et qui
sont fait attraper dans des endroits
différents donc ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'à un moment donné il y a
une information l'information elle part
de la basse oui parce que si on
saisissait trop de marchandises les
équipes ont une suspicion sur le
fournisseur bien sûr le transporteur
c'est terminé
pour préserver son indique François
Thierry il aurait donc laissé écouler la
plus grande part de la drogue
pour l'avocat Philippot à Lyon il s'agit
là d'une folle dérive dans l'utilisation
des informations avant c'était les
petites trafiquants qui faisaient tomber
en s'appelant avec les policiers les
gros trafiquants maintenant ce sont les
gros trafiquants ou un gros trafiquant
qui fait tomber des petits trafiquants
de sorte que sur 10 tonnes seul 200 kg
ou 300 kg seront neutralisés le reste a
disparu dans la nature personne ne sait
ce qu'est devenu la drogue labellisée
actrice la police elle doit empêcher la
drogue de rentrer sur le territoire
national
elle ne peut pas favoriser son entrée ni
François Thierry ni son avocat n'ont
accepté de nous parler
pourtant au sein de la police judiciaire
ces dérives seraient un secret de
polichinelle
c'est ce que nous confie Thomas de PJ
à l'actrice cela ferait bien longtemps
que l'on ne s'inquiète plus de perdre
des quantités astronomiques de drogue
on continue à franchir les limites et
puis aujourd'hui la quantité pour les
enfants abstractions une lande dérive
qui aurait mené l'actrice sans se lutter
contre les stups à en favoriser
l'importation pour le plus grand profit
des informateurs les tons tombent dans
le jargon policier
alors après je suis la proportion
justement c'est là que ça pose problème
c'est que tu dis bon à côté il y a 15
tonnes qui servent par exemple au tonton
et puis de l'autre côté la le Christ a
fait qu'une tonne de saisie ah oui c'est
ça qui va être choquant c'est qu'on
imagine que le lundi qui va permettre de
faire saisir plus de drogues que ce qui
passe alors là on a l'impression que
c'est un peu l'inverse
c'est
la drogue disparaît mais qu'en est-il
des trafiquants
l'objectif de François Thierry ce serait
de démanteler de Grosso mais pour
certains comme Hubert avoine cet
objectif n'est guère crédible
[Musique]
il n'y a pas de réseau de démanteler
parce que si on démantèle devrait réseau
mais on va démanteler sauf faire l'ampli
il n'y avait pas de lutte contre le
trafic illicite des stupéfiants en
France sans arrêter rempli
Sophia nambly n'a pas été arrêté il a
même été protégé
d'autres services comme la brigade des
stupéfiants de Paris avait eu vent du
trafic qu'il menait mais François
Thierry leur avait demandé de laisser
tranquille cette informateur si précieux
reste une question quels étaient les
motivations du commissaire François
Thierry
elles sont encore en partie mystérieuse
à ce jour l'enquête n'a pas démontré
qu'il se serait enrichi grâce aux
livraisons de cannabis
l'argent peut être pas la carrière peut
être promise au plus haute destinée
François Thierry cacher d'ailleurs à
peine ses ambitions la lutte contre le
trafic elle doit se faire à tous les
niveaux c'est pas une fausse réponse
c'est pour vous dire que chacun est
frais vous êtes prêt à faire de la
politique enfin peut-être mais c'est pas
du tout car son alliance avec Ambly lui
permettait d'afficher de beaux résultats
si des quantités colossales de drogue
disparaissent l'actrice procédait tout
de même à des saisies ainsi le policier
affirme avoir saisi grâce à Sofiane
Hambly 60 tonnes de cannabis en 6 ans
un bilan en trompe l'oeil pour certains
ce chiffre il est positif à l'origine et
impressionne en réalité il est
insignifiant regard des quantités qui
sont rentrées donc ce 60 tonnes en
réalité c'est pas un élément à des
charges pour la police c'est un élément
à charge très lourd il n'est que la face
émergée de l'iceberg pendant des années
Sophia n’oublie aurait importé bien plus
de drogues qu'il n'en a fait saisir
ainsi une note d'un service concurrent
de l'autrice la brigade des stupes de
Paris mentionne un tuyau reçu en 2012
sur le trafic d'Ambly le renseignement
faisait état du fait qu'il dirigeait
depuis sa prison un réseau réalisant une
importation d'une dizaine de tonnes de
résine de cannabis chaque mois
10 tonnes par mois soit 120 tonnes pour
une seule année c'est environ le tiers
de la consommation française
plusieurs enquêtes en cours établiront
peut-être un jour la réalité des
chiffres
des quantités astronomiques de cannabis
qu'on voyait en France sous l'égide de
la police aurait donc alimenté le trafic
pendant des années
un comble alors que chaque année 60 000
personnes sont condamnées pour
consommation ou trafic de stup
aujourd'hui Sofiane Ambly est incarcéré
mise en examen pour importation de
stupéfiant en bande organisé il risque
30 ans de prison
lui aussi mis en examen François Thierry
a été laissé libre il a quitté la police
judiciaire muté dans un autre service du
ministère de l'Intérieur
cette affaire Marco si l'échec de notre
politique antidrogue les Français sont
les premiers consommateurs de cannabis
en Europe
[Musique]